Good morning, John. Last week, the consensus to my question about why
we like to dance to songs we don't understand the words to,
was that we can hear the passion in the words
but then we can project our individual circumstances onto
their, like, blank canvas, which I thought was really quite nice, and made sense.
But then I got obsessed with what the words actually meant.
So I recruited some translators through Twitter,
not to translate word for word, but to translate the meaning.
And then, I crammed that meaning, or attempted to,
into like a cover of the song in English, but with the original meaning.
So yeah, I'm probably about to ruin these songs for you by eliminating your ability
to project your subconscious onto the nonsense of their words.
I don't care, though. Deal.
[Gangnam Style - Psy]
Gangnam is a district in Seoul that is like, a super wealthy district,
and a lot of people that don't live there try to act like they live there,
and that can result in people struggling terribly to maintain that image,
and we have this problem in America, too.
Gangnam Style at first appears to be celebrating that culture,
but then it turns out in fact that it's mocking the culture of materialism and wealth.
So, that's pretty cool.
D-d-dance!
[Macarena - Los del Rio]
This was the only verse that was in the version of the Macarena that we heard,
and it sounds pretty innocuous, but then,
the next verse in the original version of the Macarena...
Macarena's boyfriend gets drafted into the army,
and then she "listens to her body" and has sex with two of his friends,
and then wants to go shopping a lot, and it turns out that she's just a terrible person.
So, dance!
[Dragostea Din Tea - O Zone]
So this guy keeps calling this girl, who's presumably his ex or current girlfriend.
She won't pick up, so he's leaving messages.
He keeps talking about how cool he is,
and relating himself to all these epic Romanian cultural icons,
and then he's just wailing about how she's leaving him,
and relating their love to a Romanian epic poem.
It's very sad. So dance party!
[Promise - Hirose Kohmi]
I thought it was gonna be,
"get down, I shake it and I shake it and I do a little dance."
Instead, she appears to be singing about the eternal pledge
that she made to her dead or otherwise lost lover and
now is alone in the cold, cold winter, which, according to one of the translators
is a Japanese symbol for a perfect thing in an imperfect setting,
which I guess would be her perfect pledge to a dead guy.
Get down!
I also translated Soulja Boy!
[Crank Dat - Soulja Boy]
Yeah. So. I never wanna dance to that song again.
I apologize for ruining all these songs for you.
Thank you to my Romanian and Korean and Japanese and Spanish translators,
and thank you for Michael Aranda for mixing and auto-tuning those,
'cause I can't do the things that those people do.
And John, I'll see you on Tuesday.